hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to cluster truck now I
where am i hell I'm in hell okay so I
saw that this game had clustered no I
saw that this game had I track her
integration so I don't know how that
works
and I don't know what that entails but
it can't be good because I've raised it
this game when I could use my mouse and
my keyboard if I have to use my eyes and
I'm going through hell just with my eyes
I'm going to be very mad but again I
don't know how this is gonna work or if
it's gonna work or maybe oh oh my god
it's working kind of its his running
like a pile of dicks oh my god I'm
looking at it I'm looking at it I'm
looking at where I want to be mm-hmm I
don't think it works all I gotta do is
see my target whoa what okay all right I
don't know what why is this why is this
running like such [ __ ] okay hang on a
second okay let's try this again okay
all right I'm not using my mouse in it
am i right
it doesn't it doesn't work this doesn't
work really think this works it doesn't
it it just it just don't work it's the
unfortunate thing about it it's just
don't work it kind of work way if I do
not use my mouse I have not been using
my mouse this entire time I am simply
whoa oh [ __ ] okay
looking around waiting for the opportune
[ __ ] if this is extremely difficult and
I don't see how this is any better I'm
not assuming that controlling this with
your eyes would be any better than
normal gameplay of it which which is
frustrating by itself but at the same
same time I just was hoping that there
was gonna be a little more involvement
with my actual eyes than there has been
which there hasn't been really much I
guess me
is it working you know I hate to say it
but it might actually I'm at a cuz I
have not touched my mouth this entire
time in this entire game but it's kinda
I'm kind of seeing a little bit of a
yeah there's just like some slight head
tilted oh oh there we go oh we're
getting this okay holy [ __ ] okay here we
go here we go oh yeah
Oh get it oh oh oh now now we're on to
something
oh no oh oh no yeah yeah yeah okay no no
okay it's got it yeah oh no what huh ah
whoa ha ha
no no no no no oh no no how did I
survive that oh sure shitty teddies no
please I don't wanna die you know you
think that after an amazing survival
like that you it would at least let me
get the glory of finishing the level but
it it don't god I'm gonna pull out my
teeth ah it's it's definitely not a fun
control scheme it's it's it's definitely
not fun to control this game with your
eyeballs if I could just get some
semblance of consistent you know the one
thing you know the one thing that I hate
about games is inconsistent control so
if I could just figure out the
consistency of it I would be so much
happier and and so much more down to
clown with this myth ah this method of
control if I could just please have some
some consistency I was making it so far
I think it's cuz I'm trying too hard
what if I just I'm not gonna look around
with my oh my god it's because every
single time that I get close to a truck
it scoots down that what did I clip a
fingernail there it scoots down to like
two frames a second oh my god it's it's
combining all of my least favorite
things in the world which is low
framerate and inconsistent controls oh
my god oh my god can I please no that's
my ride
if I don't get this and two shakes of a
lamb's tail
I'm gonna lose my ah just please I want
it's the most straightforward level you
could possibly have it's it's literally
just a straight shot to the finish so if
I could no my god oh my oh my god oh my
god there's no way to go faster than the
speed that I'm going right right what if
I just what if I just stay here what if
I just ride this out cuz it's gonna be a
cluster truck anyway so why not just
stay on this boy that's why cuz there's
nothing oh yeah you're just you're
doomed no I wasn't dude those the one
time I could have made it through god of
course damn it of course damn it oh my
god
who are you I I you know I was never I
was never really in love with this games
control scheme to begin with I was never
really in love with it never really in
love with it now I'm really a whole lot
of not in love with it now I'm really
wishing like that there was there was
some way to not be in love with this
thing which I'm not currently God if I
could just get two frames in front of
another just put one frame in front just
play one frame in front of the other i
god damn wish in my life that you could
just put go dry you know how like games
they have one frame and then another
Oh guys hand simulator all over the
world over again frames ah goddammit
there goes my friends my friends I can't
grab a [ __ ] grenade before you
[ __ ] research for my weight frames
French police freeze frame I hate you
restart four frames for my frames my
frames are not working my frames if you
could just restart four frames that'd be
really frames frames frames just please
begging you I'm begging you game oh my
god oh my god oh my god just this guy
once again I'd like to reiterate I'm not
using my mouse at all
I am purely controlling by my balls of
eyes which is I'm pretty sure when they
invented the computer they did not
assume that you'd be controlling it with
your eyeballs oh my god oh my god oh my
god oh my god okay I'm gonna get real
quiet for a second because I'm gonna
concentrate
I'm not [ __ ] around here if you if I
could get that moment that moment to not
lag so that I could see where a truck is
if I could just win that hand comes up
over the crevasse and hits a truck if I
could just get like the actual game did
not lag like a bag of spoons in a
garbage disposal I would be so happy oh
my god oh my god oh my god why am i
going up
I feel like I don't even need to look oh
my god
I would have hit that if I could see
where it's like I have to make a leap of
faith and hope that the truck is there
when I get there because if it's not
there my cream into the abyss that was
fine
oh it's fine there was no lag there I
can't blame it on lag I realize now that
I'm blaming this on lag and you know
frankly I'm not really upset that I'm
blaming it on lag I just think oh oh did
I beat have I God I was finally going
fast enough house finally going fast
enough
ha brick I'm going very quick now wait I
think I've remembered how to go fast oh
it's just quick low jumps that's all it
is and I'll beat the time [ __ ] this
lag will be the death of me hey oh my
pinky hurts from just holding down the
shift button look at that no I don't
care about air time I don't I don't care
about air time I want the opposite of
air time I want just bouncy bouncy see
bouncy my leg the lag the thing is I
feel like the I controls would be fine
but if if I could just work I'm gonna
stab something I'm gonna stab I'm gonna
stab I'm a step I feel like the eye
tracker is getting less and less able to
control because there's so much blood
being forced into my eyeballs at the
moment that it can't possibly read my
eyes properly oh my god oh my god please
just I the most inconsistent piece of
[ __ ] I've ever seen in my life I don't
care about air time
I just want to beat this [ __ ] oh
my god how have I not beaten this
frickin level the lag don't care why
you're not mmm
God I'm a loser I am I'm literally gonna
lose my mind I'm literally gonna laughs
I'm gonna lose it
I'm gonna lose it I'm losing this is the
[ __ ] worst thing this is worse than
[ __ ] Bennett foggy it's worse than
anything I've ever done because it's so
frustrating just because it's lagging
God and I could hit my targets if it's
just wouldn't wow if I just kind of keep
my head low and scoop into it I think
that's like oh that's like the best bet
I have to getting where I need to go
faster I do have like a double jump but
it's only if I don't actually jump on
the thing god I swear I swear if you
could just be [ __ ] consistent that is
all I ask this is probably terrible to
watch cuz a kid [ __ ]
just gonna watch ah there's nothing
there's nothing anyway [ __ ] fine you
know what maybe if I just freakin wait
if I just wait if I'm not a name for
some reason you know I'm trying to beat
it there but I know I know that I'm not
gonna be able to beat it there so why
don't I just wait until the hand goes
away maybe the hand doesn't go all the
way across but [ __ ] how did I with my
[ __ ] forehead flip that [ __ ] truck
okay okay okay
so I swear I swear I don't think that
being patient is gonna work
mostly because I just don't care but
also I just think something about war
there was just no there's nothing worse
it's getting worse it's getting worse
I've got somehow it's [ __ ] worse just
go it's so it's not gonna let me beat
this because it's garbage
look at this garbage look at this
garbage it is just a big old steaming
pile of garbage
it's a big [ __ ] pile of to frame a
second carpet the ice records not even
working anymore wait no the eye tracker
shut off oh my god it just shut off and
literally shut off my eye tracker it
disconnected itself it just [ __ ] died
my eye tracker just died I'm gonna just
do it with my mouse
I'm trying I'm just gonna load up the
game no eye tracker it's just gonna play
and that's all there is to it that it is
still I can't [ __ ] beat this cuz it's
I'm in hell I'm literally of literally
it out of literally I'm just in hell I'm
in hell I'm in hell and it's the worst
and I hate it
I can't it's just impossible
it's impulsion I'm [ __ ] done I don't
know why that that runs like a turd in a
laundry machine but oh my god that is it
for cluster truck forever I don't know
what happened to the game in between the
last time I played it between that and
the first time I turned all the
graphical settings on low it doesn't
[ __ ] work I am done with that so
thank you everybody so much for watching
I think my eye tracker has exploded but
just in case it hasn't and you want me
to play a different game or do something
else with it thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video bye
[Music]
you